mais d'abord la naissance en france du
premier bébé sélectionnés grâce à la
génétique
valentin va très bien et c'est une
information en soi car sa mère est
porteuse d'une maladie génétique très
grave qu'elle aurait pu lui transmettre
grâce au diagnostic prédictif c'est un
embryon sain qui a été réimplantée une
première réalisée par les équipes de
l'hôpital béclère à clamart
dominique dumas déjà pratiqué aux états
unis et dans plusieurs pays d'europe
le diagnostic préimplantatoire a permis
à valentin de naître à clamart sans la
maladie génétique grave qui atteint le
foie et dont souffraient déjà ses trois
frères et soeurs pour cela il aura fallu
prélever des cellules sur des embryons
de trois jours issus de ses parents et
fécondés in vitro
après avoir déterminé lequel était
indemne du gène de la maladie
l'embryon été réimplanté dans l'utérus
de la mère
une opération désormais possible il
s'agit bien d'aider des couples qui
souffrent de maladies génétiquement
transmissibles question la seule
possibilité qui nous était offerte pour
aider ses cours à ne pas vivre à nouveau
la souffrance d'une interruption
médicale de grossesse quand je dit l'une
c'est parfois deux trois quatre cinq
cent mille cas de grossesse qui faisait
suite à des décès d'enfants
c'est donc un espoir pour de nombreux
couples atteints de maladies génétiques
même si la loi sur la bioéthique de 94
exige un certain nombre de garanties
il s'agit de soigner et non de choisir
par exemple le sexe de l'enfant
malheureusement cela nous a fait prendre
un retard qui a nécessité je dirais
force de la force de conviction de
convaincre les parlementaires de donner
l'autorisation dans les indications
précises et dans un cadre tout à fait
des limites et à ce qu'il y ait une
réponse en france au couple qui
souffrait de cette de ce risque
la loi de 94 veut éviter les dérives
même si elle peut sassou plaisir nous
sommes pas dans de la prestation de
services il s'agit bien d'un enfant à
naître est donc ce sont des mesures
législatives qui s'imposent et à cet
égard il est vrai que nous loi dite de
bioéthique doivent évoluer doivent être
revus régulièrement et qu'il est urgent
de revoir le texte de 94 qu'on aurait
déjà dû rediscuter en 99 il existe
désormais en france 3 centre de
diagnostic préimplantatoire permettant
le traitement d'une quinzaine de
maladies génétiques transmissibles